(CHEERING)
(CHUCKLES)
I know, it's a--
It's a happy time.
Great. I know.
Thank you.
Well, I know, I know, I know!
(LAUGHING)
It's St. Pat--
It's St. Patrick's Day tomorrow.
It's not about me,
it's St. Patrick's Day.
As if we need another reason
to drink, huh?
(LAUGHING)
Boy, no more of those
"Kiss me, I'm Irish" buttons
in the Me Too era.
(LAUGHING)
I saw one today, it said,
"Kiss me, I'll sue your ass."
(LAUGHING)
Yeah, the Irish prime minister
was at the White House,
at least we honor
that tradition still,
gave Trump
the bowl of shamrocks.
A plant from Ireland for
a plant from Russia.
(LAUGHING)
Well... (CHUCKLES)
Well, I gotta tell you about
Russia, I mean,
it's good to know, you know,
that Trump is at the helm
when you hear about new attacks
as we did this week from Russia.
Homeland Security,
did you see this,
says that Russian hackers
have been in our infrastructure
since March of 2016.
I'm talking about
the electric grid,
and they're saying they could
turn it off now,
nuclear power,
also aviation systems,
that could be the scariest.
They say the Russians already
have the capability
to create utter chaos
by calling all four boarding
groups at once.
(LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE)
No, but with Russia,
this is the week,
this is the week that
Robert Mueller
crossed the Rubicon
because he subpoenaed
Trump's business records.
(CHEERING)
This is...
This is the ball game here.
You know, because Trump always
said this is his red line,
you know, "Don't look at my
business records."
Well, that's where
the whole game is.
And I think this has made
the President crazier than ever,
I mean, the shakeups
at the Trump White House
and Casino
are...
(LAUGHING)
Have just gone into overdrive.
We have a new
Secretary of State,
you know Rex Tillerson
got the ax on Tuesday,
he seemed at peace with it,
he said,
"I've undone
all I can undo here."
(LAUGHING)
So... (CHUCKLES)
Rex was replaced at State by
the CIA Director, Mike Pompeo,
and the new top deputy at State
is Heather Nauert,
who used to be on
Fox and Friends.
And Gary Cohn,
who got shitcanned last week
as the Chief Economic Adviser,
is being replaced
by Larry Kudlow,
who Trump watches on CNBC.
You see a pattern here?
(LAUGHING)
Next week he's replacing
Jeff Sessions with Matlock.
(LAUGHING)
It's just who he sees on TV.
(APPLAUSE)
And that's not all,
other cabinet people,
the heads of cabinets who are
about to be fired,
they say the Housing dude,
that's Ben Carson,
Veterans Affairs guy
is ready to go,
National Security Adviser,
again we're gonna be
without one of those.
And the people who remain
just switch the jobs.
The CIA Director is replacing
the Secretary of State
and it looks like
the Energy Secretary
is gonna be replacing
the VA Secretary,
and he wants the EPA head to be
replacing the Attorney General,
and Ivanka is replacing Melania.
But other than that...
(LAUGHING AND APPLAUSE)
...there's no turnover.
Trump... (CHUCKLES)
...he's not running
a government,
he's running a temp agency,
it's...
(LAUGHING)
It's like he's calling
a square dance.
♪ Swing your partner
Do-si-do ♪
♪ Rex is gone
Here's Pompeo ♪
(LAUGHING)
Not normal, young people,
not normal.
(LAUGHS)
Even Trump wives
are starting to leave.
Don Jr.'s wife,
did you see this, yes.
(CHEERING)
Yes, Donny Fuckface, his, uh...
His wife filed for divorce,
she's citing
irreconcilable douchiness.
(LAUGHING)
Says, uh... Says she wants to
see other creeps.
(LAUGHING)
No, but it's sad,
we don't know
why they broke up,
you never really know, right,
with a couple,
but, uh, I'm gonna go with
Hope Hicks, I'm just gonna...
(LAUGHING)
But le-- CHUCKLES)
But let's end another
unbelievable week
in the Trump era with--
And a week, by the way,
he was here,
in California for the--
Did you see that?
(BOOING)
(CHUCKLES) I know.
He went wall shopping,
he was...
He went to San Diego to look at
swatches.
(LAUGHING)
But let's... (CHUCKLES)
But let's end
on a positive note,
there was a special election
in Pennsylvania and...
(CHEERING)
Oh, you heard about it, okay.
Liberals are...
Liberals are very happy
that this guy, Conor Lamb,
is the apparent winner.
They say he is a new kind of
Democrat, 'cause he won.
(LAUGHING)
He won something.
And I love this, Trump went to
Pennsylvania,
campaigned against him,
of course, slandered him--
The second Conor Lamb won,
Trump said, "Well, he won
because he's like me."
"Like me."
This guy's 33 years old,
has a full head of hair,
when he looks down naked
he can see his penis...
(LAUGHING)
...he was in the Marine Corps,
he's never gone bankrupt,
never colluded
with the Russians,
never paid hush money
to a porn star,
other than that
it's like looking in the mirror.
(LAUGHING)